Existen algunos patrones
interesantes en los números binarios.
He encontrado que, al comprender estos patrones,
tengo una mejor intuición del número binario con
el que estoy trabajando. Así que veamos
algunos de estos patrones en este vídeo.
Empecemos con los números impares. El número
3 del sistema decimal es impar y en binario
es 0011. Ahora, el número 5 del sistema
decimal que es impar en binario es 0101,
el 7 del sistema decimal en binario es
0111, finalmente el 9 en binario es 1001.
Entonces, ¿notaste el patrón en estos
números binarios? Te daré una pista si
no lo has encontrado.
¡Tan tan tan tan tan!
Todos estos números binarios terminan
en 1, de hecho la única forma de que un
número sea impar en el sistema de numeración
binario es que termine en 1. Esto se debe a
que el 1 está en la posición de las unidades y
cualquier otra posición es una potencia de 2.
Recuerda un número impar es un número que
al dividirlo entre 2 queda un residuo de 1,
eso significa que siempre tenemos
que tener un 1 en la posición de
las unidades para crear un número impar.
Ahora podemos ver cualquier número binario
y saber si es par o impar, así que probemos
luego con algunos números muy grandes.
¿Cuál de estos es impar? Bueno, vayamos
a la posición de las unidades y veamos.
Cero, cero, uno, cero. Muy bien, este es el
número impar, todos los demás son pares. Entonces,
aunque no tenemos una idea de qué número son
estos, sabemos que éste es un número impar,
y con esto tenemos una mejor
intuición de los números binarios.
Pero sigamos explorando y veamos qué más hay.
Otro patrón interesante lo encontramos cuando
el número binario tiene solamente unos,
es decir, podemos tener el 1 el 11 el
111 y el 1111, ¡un montón de unos!
Entonces, en el sistema decimal este
primer valor es lo mismo que 1, 3 es 11 en
binario, 7 es 111, y 15 es 1111. Entonces,
¿qué tienen de especial estos números decimales
que encontramos, es decir 1, 3, 7 y 15?
Tal vez no sea obvio al principio, pero cada uno
de ellos es de hecho una potencia de 2 menos 1. Es
decir, este 1 es lo mismo que 2 menos 1, 3 es lo
mismo que 4 menos 1, 7 es lo mismo que 8 menos 1,
y 15 es lo mismo que 16 menos uno.
Podemos escribir esto en términos de
potencia es de 2 esto es 2 a la 1 menos 1, 2 a la
2 menos 1, 2 a la 3 menos 1, y 2 a la 4 menos 1.
Por lo tanto, cuando un número binario solo tiene
unos en todas sus posiciones entonces siempre será
igual al número más grande que puede representarse
por este número de bits. Esto es muy parecido a lo
que pasa en el sistema decimal cuando tenemos
números como el 9, 99, 999 y 9999. Si sumamos
1 pasaremos al siguiente valor posicional y, por
lo tanto, este es el valor más grande que se puede
expresar con ese número de dígitos. Esto es lo que
estamos viendo por aquí. También podemos escribir
el número de bits con el que estamos trabajando
por aquí. Si nos fijamos en el número de bits
tenemos un bit, 2 bits, 3 bits, y 4 bits. Así que
podemos ver que para 4 bits el número más grande
que podemos representar es 2 elevado a la 4 menos
uno. Para 3 es 2 elevado a la 3 menos 1, etcétera.
Eso significa que si sabemos el número de bits que
tenemos sabremos el valor más grande que podemos
representar con ese número de bits, y sabremos
que ese valor será a tener un 1 en cada posición.
Así que podemos usar esta información para
ayudarnos a comprender mejor los números binarios.
Entonces, considera este número binario 1 1 1 1
1 ¿A qué es igual en el sistema decimal? Bueno,
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 bits, así que este debe de ser
igual a 2 elevado a la 5 menos 1. 2 elevado a las
5 es lo mismo que 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 que es
lo mismo que 32. Y si le restamos 1 obtenemos 31.
Entonces, sin tener que sumar todos estos valores
encontramos de manera sencilla el resultado.
Ahora bien, también podemos hacerlo a la antigua,
así que veamos: posición del 1, posición del 2,
posición del 4, posición del 8, posición del
16, y podemos decir que 16 más 8 son 24 más 4
son 28 más 2 son 30 más uno es 31.
Entonces de cualquier manera que
lo hagamos obtendremos el mismo valor.
Esto nos da otra forma de entender los
números binarios y de poder tener
una mejor intuición sobre ellos.